une machine tueuse de couronnes navires
us c'est le projet mise au point par
cette entreprise de fontenay le fleury
elle a choisi de chercher des solutions
pour aider à lutter contre l'épidémie de
lakovic 19 en mettant son activité
première de côté les deux machines qui
ont été créés la première c'est la lampe
du veston qui a été conçu pour pouvoir
nettoyer doit pouvoir désinfecter des
pièces par exemple une salle de réunion
un cabinet de médecin une salle d'école
qui utilisent des néons uvc qui viennent
bombardé entièrement toute la caisse
la deuxième machine elle a été créée au
cours d'une rencontre on proposait notre
lampe à un opticien qui nous exprimer
son besoin lui de pouvoir d infecter des
petits objets on a créé lui vblocks qui
est un boîtier de 18 qui permet de
pouvoir désinfecter en 30 secondes
les objets qui sont placés dans la
technologie utilisée à la diffusion de
rayons uv c à manier avec précaution car
potentiellement dangereux pour l'homme à
forte exposition les us et son efficace
contre tous qui va contenir de l'adn les
virus les bactéries les sports les
champignons on a une dizaine d'années de
d'études médicales qui ont été menées
sur différents germes pour déterminer
les doses nécessaires pour désactiver tu
es différent pathogènes pour l'instant
une dizaine de lampes uv storm ainsi que
cinq bbox ont été assemblés au sein même
de l'entreprise
elle souhaite prioriser la production
sur le territoire c'est important de
pouvoir travailler le plus possible
localement d'avoir le plus possible de
la production et de la recherche et de
l'ingénierie qui est fait ici
l'entreprise travaille actuellement sur
un troisième produit adapté aux
particuliers notamment les ménages avec
enfants mais ces machines ne sont pas
des solutions miracles et doivent être
utilisés en complément des principaux
gestes barrières